I have to do a speech on dark night or
get to the hotels in Chicago and all of
a sudden there's a speech waiting for me
there and I'm going they're giving me
the speech now and it's like this long
speech and I go I had this idea of what
I was going to say I was like why was I
thinking that that was ever gonna go but
now I was like no I'm gonna have to
memorize that yeah it was like 10
o'clock at night I was like were you
stressed yeah were you nervous of course
anxiety it's massive and it's like
there's gonna be 1200 extras how did you
do it awfully so I I was up all night
learning it finally I I remember being
there with 1200 you know extra
background workers they're in the middle
of the financial district of Chicago I'm
supposed to give this speech you know
and he's using an IMAX camera which is
like 200 Grand a take is what I'm
thinking like these things are massive
and so expensive and uh and sure enough
I'm doing this after walking this parade
with uh with Maggie Gyllenhaal and you
know and then and so I I go to Maggie
it's like Maggie can you just look at
this I don't even know her I was like I
just see if I'm off book here so I'm
like running lines with Maggie as we're
walking